what do you think about the whole um
decent sorry thing are you but you don't
know the whole story so yeah I guess you
can't really I I think that and I'm
gonna be so we don't edit this thing
alright sorry George I had to so that we
don't edit this thing is that I wasn't
there yeah I mean my take on it was that
you know the girl is like 22 23 and
obviously she consented to being there
at one point she was fully naked with
him but he just sounds like a [ __ ]
creep he kept trying to like shove his
fingers down her throat multiple times
and after when she realized the move
that's an Indian yeah I know yeah yeah I
mean like I I've been in that position
where I was so young and naive and I
thought that I owed it to the guy or
else I wouldn't get a ride home from
Reseda and I'm like [ __ ] I have no money
I'm gonna get stuck here I better
[ __ ] blow him and I'm feeling really
sick about it after cuz like you know I
have felt like either coerced but I'm so
[ __ ] young and stupid that I didn't I
couldn't handle myself appropriately at
that time that would never happen to me
now I'd be very like [ __ ] no get on my
[ __ ] face I'm gone those will be
pretty merry upset with you I think I've
always also been a what and looking back
and I can applaud myself I don't know
why but I've always been I've had single
times where I've you know saw certain
girls and it didn't you know work out
but I've never done a dine and dash
situation what pop and run I'll tell you
why your there's something so cute about
you I think that you have a perpetual
fear of rejection because when we first
met he would ask everything was a
permission where I wanted to get really
grimy and do so I would do crazy [ __ ]
like spit in his face or spit in his
mouth and just get like super hyper
sexual and at the moment he would feel
me either like or he would suspect that
maybe I wasn't feeling something he'd be
like oh like we were so like over
sensitive about feeling rejected but I
think if I had told you hey I don't want
to do that you'd be okay I'll go home
that's what you would know because all
the relationship
I've had before you were like with
younger girls and girls that more are
more suburban II the [ __ ] no you're more
i mean you you're a little bit more the
island island island flavor island
flavor where it was just what i've never
really quite met somebody that was like
there was one girl that data that i've
never even seen her ass whoa
yeah she goes i just don't hit my ass so
she could she would get up from the bed
and face me and back away from yeah late
at night i would try to you know mean to
the towels and i mean at the blanket
thing where i was she's sleeping on her
stomach so i can look at it that way but
then she would just turn how do the
jeans it looks pretty [ __ ] flat yeah
that's why I know but still I wanted to
see the flesh part yeah cuz it never
looks as bad well just it looks flat
through the jeans it's not so bad yeah
but like you know well the worst thing
about asses if I see pimples I've had
but pimples no I like no like why are
you so I've had like eight at one time
yeah I showed you and then you said yeah
I didn't like what I say you asked to
put your dick in my butt yeah cuz the
pic out of anger to be like oh yeah rage
rage yeah I'll try to pop your pimples
yeah yeah I am
but I said when I met you it was just
like I never had a girl say to me choke
me you mean or because you love me you
were so careful like he never he wasn't
the aggressor and I was very much the
aggressor I can never picture you in a
scenario where you like force your like
your fingers down somebody's throat or
like chase them around the room and like
please have sex with me like I've I can
never picture you that way cuz you're
such you're a guy who has just been
perpetually rejected and they think that
you you fear you still fear that to some
degree oh my god I was perpetually
rejected I bagged it many times
a bit hurt and scarred I've chased not
sexually just dating-wise it's no
dating-wise no eat my heart I mean what
I mean is that I've longed you've
courted I've courted have longed for
women and they've just completely
friend-zoned me and then on the type of
guy that's be stay in the friendzone for
a year and then watch them date other
guys and get jealous and I would write
poetry real
I would used to write poetry about it I
have Diaries for a lot I don't want a
girl I used to go to Zanzibar coffee
shop in Pacific Beach to like 3:00 in
the morning and like to hope hopefully
I'll run into someone so yeah right and
I just played chess with my friend
Callisto and I love that method like
look around to see if Rebecca came in
Wow and she's not there maybe she'll
come I've seen her in the mornings I'll
wait because Zanzibar was 24 hours I'll
just wait till 9:00 10:00 in the morning
like I'm that guy
were you Rio is good with girls um
there's the crazy thing being like the
only Asian guy you could like I think
about age 20 I think I slept over like
200 black women you're a novelty 100
black women yeah probably because it's
not like you know like really like I
would I moved here with black women
would reject me like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with this [ __ ] you know yeah
because I'm so used to the only Asian
guys so [ __ ] it you know it's what I
grew up around so so how many - are you
being real you [ __ ] off anyone about
the count but it's probably in that
realm somewhere Wow and you found them
attractive too as well not all you know
how guys are
yeah I think my scale went from anywhere
from you know the more drugs you do your
negotiate that number all right so on a
scale of one to ten that's in terms of
african-american women right have you
ever done a one yeah whoa yeah probably
well what is the one deal precious you
know
I've really yeah I'd say one all the way
up to a nine never probably attended
have you ever ate I ate out of precious
[ __ ] no oh you wouldn't do that oh it
was basically like I'm drunk I just did
some B [ __ ] this [ __ ] you still you're
high that's how you know it's bad
your highest [ __ ] and you're still like
you took in negotiating in the bathroom
but just go to work yeah yeah I've done
that too like you know what I'm just
gonna go to the bathroom oh really
you've done that I'm gonna jerk off
after the other like I can't do you ever
do this do you ever go to like back in
San Diego we used to have F Street
bookstore mm-hmm and at 8:18 you can
walk in there yeah
and they have those booths in the back
where you watch videos hmm it smells
like calm and you ever jerked off in
those booths but my friend used to work
at one of those yes Oh crazy story about
that is a key thing but it's okay I went
there and I saw he was putting up dildos
one day right yeah it was it one of
dildos had a sticker this that thin [ __ ]
yeah oh that's a big [ __ ] subconscious
yeah I I've blown some ogres myself what
am i over I've been like I've I've
[ __ ] really ugly ugly dudes cuz they
were nice and I like them yeah I'm an
equal-opportunity employer I mean I've
found that you are because you're dating
me but you're actually in my scale of
the ugliest I've ever [ __ ] to the most
good-looking I've ever [ __ ] believe it
or not you're probably right at a seven
or eight because I've [ __ ] some
gargoyles like wow that's funny
get you women just being funny yeah just
being funny it's weird it's not just
funny it's if anyone's pursuing their
dream I think that that's infectious
yeah I think so too yeah
when somebody is every day resilient and
they keep doing it even in the face of
like
all this negative [ __ ] it's it's it
bodes well I think that's that you're
completely right all those super super
ugly guys that I [ __ ] with always had
big personalities yeah I mean without
that the what are you what are you left
with
but maybe money then after that you're
like what interest do you have after
that like yeah yeah you're broke you're
ugly you're not funny didn't you know
for what that boy I remember one of my
first boyfriends when I came here he was
like a really fat Mexican guy named Josh
and he would visit mean his like BMX
bike and I was so in love with him he
was a gangster and I and and I then I
dated a gangster from [ __ ] you're not
gonna believe this but his name was
puppet it's really most Victor and he
was a really nice guy hair tattoos you
meet up with puppet yeah and then what
puppet I you [ __ ] pop no I blew puppet
you blew popper I blew the [ __ ] out of
puppet the puppet never entered the
house he no I would go visit him in
China
no no no he was I was underage and he
was over there gangster I do love it's
so funny I took a lot of time I go if we
if she didn't know who I was
and we met we were went to high school
she would not even give me the light of
day what I just told you I puppet I'm
not puppet I think I think I'm on your
side with that I think he she would
still yeah I think you don't know you
don't know me yeah back then no I was
greasy I was the kid at the library
right who's sitting there in the corner
and it's like winter but sweating and
I'm sitting there sweating I always had
sweaty palms right and I would just wait
until people left so I can truck off to
like incest books and stuff Oh Jimmy
okay like those sight you know I can't
believe I just said that yeah there was
sex ed books about arm about like and
these are like medicals books about
incest and stuff like sanity there's
like drawings yeah and I used to jerk
off to that show so you know you're not
baby you're not gonna I
guarantee you guarantee or not guarantee
you if you were even if we let's say we
were just friends and I just happened to
be bored that day I was such a horny kid
that I would have been like okay I guess
you know let's do this then you know
that we meeting you would have changed
the trajectory of my life I'm glad we
didn't meet then yeah because I would
have got some [ __ ] and and and getting
[ __ ] would have been bad for me because
the only reason why I got into comedy is
to get [ __ ] right so maybe I don't know
it's great that I didn't meet someone
like you yeah so started where we are
time we're over about an hour wow that's
cool